Steve Bannon former white house chief
political strategist in the Trump
Administration is expected to turn
himself in this morning to face new
criminal charges of wrongdoing
prosecutors in New York City are due to
reveal a reported indictment that Bannon
calls phony as Robert Costa reports the
charges may be very similar similar
rather to a federal court case that
never went to trial
longtime Trump allies Steve Bannon is
now likely facing State charges with a
Criminal indictment expected in New York
such charges May revive a past
controversy Bannon once phase federal
fraud charges related to we build the
wall Incorporated a fundraising
operation that sought to build private
sections of the wall along the U.S
Mexico border and raised 25 million
dollars the bowered panel the justice
department alleged that Bannon
personally received more than a million
dollars from we build the wall but early
last year Trump pardoned Bannon before
he could be brought to trial on the
federal charges see Bannon could be in
great legal Jeopardy in terms of prison
in Time CBS News legal analyst Ricky
cleeman while the state courts and the
federal courts are separate entities
we look at something called double
jeopardy as to whether someone could be
tried twice for the same crime well here
Steve Bannon was never tried he was
pardoned by former president Trump so he
was never put in Jeopardy so the state
had every right to go forward in a
statement Bannon wrote this is nothing
more than a partisan political
weaponization of the Criminal Justice
System Trump won binds illegitimate this
comes just weeks after the former Trump
adviser was convicted of contempt of
congress for refusing to cooperate with
the January 6 committee investigating
the attack on the capitol a judge
recently denied Bannon his request for a
new trial
[Applause]
meanwhile the legal standoff continues
in the probe of former president Trump's
handling of sensitive documents tomorrow
is the deadline for the justice
department and Trump's lawyers to
present a list of candidates for the
role of special master that outside
attorney would independently review the
documents in the government's possession
and it was one month ago today that the
FBI searched Mar-A-Lago Tony
Bob thank you very much